Islamic center there and school.
no children were harmed and you know
from what I understand the attempt
was to access the school but
alhamdulillah it was locked down
properly and
rendered inaccessible.
having said that, we have hired armed
security for the remaining four school
days here so
we've only got a few more days left of
school so
for that time we'll be keeping the
especially during Dhuhr salah and
during the daytime we won't be using the
usual sandbag, you know, keeping it
propped open. We want to keep it closed
and probably
hereforth it's not really a good
practice to have a door that locks
automatically but then
you know, propped open anybody could
just get in so we're going to
keep monitoring the situation but
we ask Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
to
[Arabic recitation]
brothers who
were
who were killed in the altercation.
Nas'al Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
You know, sometimes it's like
you live in a place this and
it feels like
you know, being chosen for martyrdom is
so far-fetched and then it comes right
to your doorstep, right? And it's like
subhanallah.
you almost you can't help but feel a bit
of jealousy.
Continuing in Kitab
So,
we discussed yesterday
the
the relative purity
of the tail of a woman's dress
with respect to the tail of a man's
clothing.
And we said that
this is one of the instances where
a woman's
dress
is given a pass because of the
circumstances and because of the
precedence of the greater good, which is
concealing the aura, right? Concealing
the zina. And so, even though Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala of course knows that
a
byproduct of having a longer tail is
that it will be more prone to
dirt, more prone to a najasah. However,
the Sharia weighs
the
weighs the evils of both.
So, it weighs the personal evil of a
najasah on a part of the clothing and
the public evil of
and and personal evil of
a woman's awrah in public being
exposed and gives precedence to the
public
awrah being exposed as being more
important.
And so, that is the greater evil, so it
is
pushed away
and hence we are left with a more minor
This does not apply to a man.
And this is one of the instances where
something like
a najasah
will be different for a man than it will
for a woman in this kind of instance.
Which is very interesting because
in even
a najasat, there are exceptions.
So, we understand that even a najasah
is not a purely physical thing.
Another example of this.
The benefit of a hunting dog and the
ease that it allows
the Muslimin and the human being.
This outweighs
the otherwise
najasah of the saliva of a canine.
Correct?
This outweighs it. So, now the saliva of
a canine that is taught
and hunts only for its master and kills
only for its master
or any other kind of predatory animal.
It's not only for dogs. If a person
could train a leopard to do it
hypothetically, if a person could train
a hawk I know in some of the Khaleeji
countries, right?
they to train hawks and and
and and eagles and so forth to hunt. All
of these things
these are considered exempt. They're no
longer najis.
They are no longer najis. Why? It's the
same physiology. If we were to take
the saliva of a hunting dog
to a chemist
and the saliva of a stray dog
and
compare them in test tubes and
compare the chemical composition. Would
there be a difference? Probably.
Probably not.
Be this is from a dog and this is from a
dog.
So, it is not purely what? It is not a
purely
physical thing.
Likewise,
najasa of animals which we use.
Okay? Animals which are used as almost a
servant. So, for instance,
we took that one of the types of najasa
is
[Arabic recitation]
The
the waste
and the saliva and the blood and so
forth of an animal which is otherwise
prohibited to eat. Correct?
But then we have something a house
cat.
The prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam,
it fits the general rule. Correct? It
fits the general rule.
However,
it is
it is an exception to the general rule.
Why?
The prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam's
commented on the house cat and said,
He said, "It is not filthy."
meaning it's saliva, because it is
considered to be amongst the tawwafīn,
meaning the servants that serve the
human beings good. So, having a house
cat in the house for pests and so forth,
some scholars mention
even if the if the cat is lazy, even if
it is a coward and runs from pests,
[Arabic recitation]
occupied, cuz it's cute and cuddly and
right? It is exempt.
All right. Another example is the
domesticated donkey.
It's prohibited to eat a domesticated
donkey, right? It is halal
in the
[Arabic recitation]
mentions that the prophet Sallallahu
alaihi wasallam prohibited
the meat of domestic donkeys. And not
only that, but it was so severe that
even the pots that they were cooked in
Sallallahu alaihi wasallam
were attended to.
However,
would it be possible for us to use a
domesticated donkey and be completely
separate from it and not get any of
its saliva or any of its hair or any of
its sweat on us? Not possible. How are
you going to ride it? How are you going
to benefit from it in this instance?
So, it is overlooked.
Right? It is overlooked. Even if the
physiology may
be physically the same, and this is an
important point
that a lot of us may find difficult to
understand because we live in a time
that is so materialistic.
We are obsessed with the material. We
are obsessed with numbers. We are
obsessed with the apparent. Right?
There is a difference between our
judgment with Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
and the purely physical and the purely
material.
So, these types of animals immediately
are exempted.
Why? Because of
the context that these animals exist in.
For instance, one of the types of
animals for us to
are that the general rule
of an animal which is prohibited to eat.
Do we know what the general rule is? We
will get to this in the chapter
regarding
al al al at'imah in the book of of food
and the types of meat which are
prohibited. But what is the type of
animal which is generally prohibited for
us to eat?
Right. Sabu
sabu
dhunabin
aw makhlab muftarish
right?
Is any animal that is a beast, is a land
dweller beast, means it's a carnivore,
right? It has prey.
It is
on the on the food chain hierarchy, on
the food chain, and it has either
fangs or claws that it uses to hunt with
or talons. So, this makes it prohibited
to eat something an eagle, to eat
something a hawk, or to eat
something a leopard, or to eat
something a lion, right? Or a bear.
All of these things have
fangs or claws or talons or all all
three or all two, correct?
However, the hyena
is exempted from that.
Hyena?
Sheikh Ali hyena? Yes, I
How does that fit into the rule into the
into the general principle?
It seems to not fit. That is an
exception that is given by Allah. Why?
Because of the context of place where
hyenas are predominantly found in the
Arab Peninsula. People there are dying
of hunger.
Right? And hunting is scarce.
And so, the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam gave
the companions an allowance to hunt
hyenas and continue to eat hyenas.
Now,
when I was growing up,
they old-timers would tell us that
hyenas, only the right side of the hyena
is halal.
I'm not making this up. This is
real Palestinian sawalha lore right
there that I'm putting on you. The right
side of the hyena. I don't know which
one is the right side. As a child, this
always confused me. Is it my right or
the hyena's right, right?
But it's the right side.
There's no such rule in Islamic law.
It's either permissible or
impermissible.
Right? It all has the same circulatory
system. It all has the same
But that doesn't seem to fit the rule.
Why? Because not only does it have
canines and not only is it a carnivore
and a beast, but it also usually is a
scavenger.
Correct?
It's usually a scavenger and it has
abilities akin to a vulture with respect
to rotted meat and so forth.
But this is an allowance that the
prophet
Alaihi Wasallam gave. This is not a
purely physiological thing and there's
no set rule.
The rules are set with respect to the
experience of the human being in any set
environment.
Right? So he gives us general rules and
one of those general rules from all of
these we come out with an ultimate rule
with which is
And so the general rule that all of
these things they seem to be exceptions
to the rule, but really they're not.
They all fall under a general higher
rule and that is
when things become difficult for the
person, they are made
purposely
easy by Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala.
Whenever the human being finds
in a situation where he would be
highly inconvenienced if not burdened,
Allah comes to relieve that in order for
a person not to be able to survive for a
day or a week or a year, but to thrive
for decades or even generations in any
given environment.
Subhanallah.
Which is one of the reasons why
anything that is in the sea is
permissible to eat.
Anything in the sea.
The The scholars tell us even if it has
the appearance of a pig, even if it
looks a human being. As a matter of
fact, some scholars have mentioned
mermaids in their books of fiqh.
Does this mean that mermaids exist?
[Arabic recitation]
come up with these, you know, say, "Hey,
I saw this creature. It was half human
and half fish, and it had teeth such and
such, and it looked just a human
being." And if it becomes so prevalent,
the scholars may address it in their
books.
Right?
That's not a testament that it exists,
it's a testament that if it were to
exist hypothetically, this is the law of
Allah subhana wa ta'ala with respect to
this
with respect to this creature, whether
it is mythological or otherwise.
Right? So,
ultimately,
all of the sciences are the science of
fiqh. This whole book is founded on the
essence, the essential principle of wa
ma ja'ala alaykum fi deeni min
haraj.
This entire book, this entire science
is founded on the principle of Allah has
not placed in
Allah has not placed any undue
out of the norm burden or inconvenience
upon
the human being in
Islam.
Now, the word haraj doesn't just mean
burden.
A burden
is al-kulfa or al-kell, right? That's
why we call it sinnet taklif.
Al-haraj is an inconvenience.
So,
there are rules and there are laws, but
ultimately even those laws of
prohibition are all anchored in what?
And this rule is
said by the scholars of usul al-fiqh, it
is worded as itha daqa al-amr ish
ittasa'. Itha daqa al-amr ittasa'.
So, we will continue from there tomorrow
[Arabic recitation]